[Música]
perfecto bueno recordando esas tres
preguntas que les acabo de hacer
justamente esto es lo que quiero hablar
del poder del pensamiento de nosotros
como que tienen nuestros comportamientos
en esta imagen hay un proyecto bastante
lindo
pero imagínese
imagínense que ir en el puente se
encuentra sentado un viejito que a lo
lejos de venir una persona y se da
cuenta que es un caminante es un
caminante que se acerque y le pregunta
buenas tardes usted vive en este pueblo
si así éste responde el viejito
y el caminante le pregunté mire es un
polvo hermoso la verdad que me
encantaría quedarme vivir un tiempo pero
tengo una duda cómo es la gente
que vive en este pueblo y el dígito le
responde con otra pregunta cómo era la
gente en los pueblos en los que tú has
vivido antes alocar el caminante dice
bueno la verdad la gente en los pueblos
que yo he vivido era gente negativa y
solamente veía las cosas es un enfoque
negativo nos ayudaban eran pesimistas no
apreciaban lo bueno de la vida el
apetito dice pues bueno la gente en este
pueblo es así también el caminante
decepcionado continúa su camino
minutos después se acerca un nuevo
caminante y le hacen la misma pregunta
elegís buenas tardes usted vive en este
pueblo
la verdad que es un pueblo hermoso y me
encantaría quedarme a vivir un tiempo
pero tengo una duda cómo es la gente que
vive en este pueblo y el viejito le hace
la misma pregunta cómo era la gente en
los pueblos que tú has vivido a local
este segundo caminante le responde bueno
la verdad que la gente en los pueblos
que he vivido
era gente que a pesar de los problemas
siempre trataba de encontrar la solución
era gente optimista era gente que se
colaboraba era gente solidaria era gente
que siempre trataba de encontrar el lado
positivo al ilícito él dice pues la
gente en este pueblo es igual a sí y
este segundo caminante toma la decisión
de entrar al puesto metros más allá se
encontraba un labrador trabajando en la
tierra y que fue testigo de ambas
conversaciones intrigado se acerca al 10
y félix de disculpe como usted le ha
podido responder cosas tan distintos a
estas personas que le han preguntado lo
mismo a local el viejito le responde
mira no importa lo que yo haya podido
responder
ellos estaban dispuestos a ver solamente
lo que querían ver yo sí van a ver
solamente lo que están programados y
preparados para ver
era tan cierto lo que hemos descripción
de esta historia era que las personas
solamente estamos predispuestas a ver
ciertas cosas de nuestra vida
la programación de la lingüística es un
modelo que trata de explicar cómo las
personas pensamos y generamos nuestros
procesos como ella nos dice que la mayor
parte de las cosas que realizamos las
hacemos de manera automática a través de
procesos programas mentales automáticos
quieren probar pueden cruzar los brazos
perfecto en el caso mío la mano derecha
es la que encima del brazo izquierdo y
la mano y arrastra debajo del brazo
derecho del telar
donde les diga ya traten de cristal de
tal forma que sea al revés que las manos
que han quedado debajo quedan arriba y
viceversa
activo sencillo
el fin después de anotar vamos a hacer
otro
crucen los dedos de las manos el caso
mío es izquierdo que está encima
de las manos
y he podido
tentado cuenta que en la medida que
ponemos algo que los tenemos de manera
consciente se hace más difícil
y es la misma forma que tiene las cosas
que hacen se ponen a pensar lo que
ustedes hacen en la mañana si bien se
levantan capaz que tienen una misma
frecuencia todos los días
y las mismas estrategias mentales que
utilizamos para encontrarle soluciones a
nuestros problemas utilizamos siempre y
mayormente es la razón por la cual no le
encontramos soluciones a problemas del
día a día que son recurrentes en
nosotros
la programación de la lingüística nos
dice que una vez que una idea se han
registrado en tu mente es quitar la
charla y esto es por eso porque porque
generamos tres procesos
que realizamos eliminamos y destrucción
amos la información que recibimos vamos
a ver de manera rápida cada una de ellas
analizar significa que tú tomas un
evento puntual que puede ser único y lo
extrapola al res es decir tres que él
siempre va a ocurrir vamos a un ejemplo
del ámbito laboral imagínense que en
oficina el lugar donde trabajamos acaban
de contratar un nuevo compañero
al principio como siempre asusten las
relaciones humanas no conocemos a la
persona
el nuevo compañero nos es indiferente
pero resulta que al terminar la primera
semana el día viernes el fin querer echa
su taza de café en tu escritorio y tú
qué haces no yo sabía en el caso de que
yo no le caigo a esta persona el baix al
propósito no me quiere me ve como su
competente
un evento puntual chiquitito duras
generalizados te has hecho una
conclusión basada en una sola situación
luego viene la eliminación resulta que
si bien el viernes ocurrió este
dos días antes de entrar al baño con tu
celular cuando la verdad que todos
entramos al baño con nuestro celular
porque ha ayudado a hacer más
entretenido lo que es cumplir con las
necesidades biológicas cierto pero bueno
tú entras te al baño y dejaste olvidado
tu celular en el apuro de volver a tokio
a tu escritorio resulta que fue el nuevo
compañero y agarro el celular lo
encontró y te lo devolvió versus elimina
esa información para confirmar la
creencia que te has hecho decir tú no le
caes ok y el último proceso es la
distorsión la distorsión significa darle
una significancia diferente a un evento
puntual que tú has vivido resulta que un
compañero ha echado su tacita de café en
otro escritorio no tenemos sexual idea
de que no nos quiere hemos eliminado la
información que puede posicionar aquello
pero resulta el lunes siguiente se fue
compañero preocupado por la incidencia
de peter y gen marcelo ira disculpa lo
del otro día te invito a comer
dices para dentro tuyo no
y si este tipo me odia y ahora me está
invitando a almorzar
si quiere algo de sacar mi información y
empiezas a distorsionar todo estos tres
procesos se dan de manera inconsciente
se dan al mismo tiempo es por eso que
una idea se ha clavado en tu mente es
difícil cambiarla también que es lo peor
de esto estos tres procesos definen
nuestra forma de ver la vida
se tiene nuestra forma de ver todas las
cosas entonces muchas veces nosotros nos
hacemos a la idea de que observamos la
realidad desde un enfoque objetivo y la
verdad es que no vemos la realidad del
enfoque sus objetivos simplemente vemos
lo que nuestros pensamientos nuestras
creencias nos permiten ver alguna vez
han tratado de manejar un auto cuando no
funciona los limpiaparabrisas debe ser
la cosa más incómoda a no ser que está
que es la cabeza y tratar de ver capas
no vas a encontrar la correcta dirección
y es lo mismo es lo que nos pasa las
creencias los pensamientos que tenemos
no nos dejan no nos permiten ver la
realidad como realmente a mí me encanta
comparar el poder de las creencias un
ejemplo de este pequeño arbusto alguien
sabe piquete ese árbol qué fruta de este
árbol
uva
les gusta el kiwi particularmente es una
de mis frutas favoritas han dado cuenta
que esta fruta que una semilla bien
pequeñita
capaz que no tiene más que un milímetro
de diámetro pero esta pequeña semilla
contiene toda la información genética
para desarrollar un arbusto como el que
hemos visto de casi dos metros y lo
mismo pasa con nuestras creencias
las creencias tienen la capacidad
y desarrollarnos conseguir cosas
espectaculares como también tienen la
capacidad de limitarnos a espacios muy
pequeños
ahora lo que pasa con las creencias con
sus pensamientos que muchas veces se
convierten en modelos de comportamiento
en paradigmas que rigen nuestra vida
aunque nos demos cuenta somos
prisioneros de nuestros parados somos
prisioneros de esos filtros y de sus
pensamientos que nos limitan a hablar
como realmente quisieran
ahora no solamente somos prisioneros de
nuestros paradigmas no también de
nuestros miedos y miedos muchas veces
infundados uno de ellos es por ejemplo
el miedo al rechazo
te has dado cuenta que hoy en día no
validamos nuestra identidad en función a
nuestros principios al criterio de otras
personas
quién de nosotros no tiene un perfil de
facebook por ejemplo y cuando posteamos
algo subimos una fotografía no estamos
volviendo del rato en rato para ver
cuántos like cuántos me gustaba hemos
recibido
cuando recibimos una cantidad importante
de me gusta nos sentimos bien o no pero
cuando recibimos muy poca cantidad de me
gusta empezamos a cuestionarlo y es que
estamos dándole importancia más a la
opinión de los demás en la nuestra
y el fracaso
como que vivimos en una sociedad donde
solamente se acepta o se valida a las
personas que tienen éxito
el ganar en el primero es lo que importa
y realmente a ver pongámonos a pensar
en nuestras vidas realmente conseguimos
todo en la medida que lo hemos planeado
por lo mayor lo que pasa mayormente es
que siempre estamos planificando
programando ejecutando esforzándonos por
conseguir algo pero muy pocas veces
conseguimos ese escrito que tanto
tenemos entonces como es que no se
valora el esfuerzo que está detrás del
camino en el camino
el ganar tendría que ser simplemente una
consecuencia de los valores puestos en
el trayecto
miedo a la pérdida de control tengo
cuenta que hoy
recibimos tantos estímulos que nos dicen
que nos hablan de que podemos tener
nuestra vida controlada al máximo pérez
ojos azules puede tener ojos azules
quiere saber más cabello más cabello no
te gusta primar isla puedes cambiar y
hoy en día y nos encantaría tener que
haber estudiado la profesión ideal
nos gustaría tener el trabajo ideal nos
gustaría tener la familia perfecta
planificar las vacaciones ideales
recetas etcétera hay que darnos cuenta
de que humildemente no tenemos la
capacidad de controlar todas las cosas
que están en nuestra vida y hay que
darse un abandono saludable cuando hablo
de un abandono saludable y me refiero a
saber diluir es lo más importante en tu
vida
a ver qué cosas son triviales qué es lo
realmente importante en tu vida
y esas cosas que realmente son
importantes con él es todo el corazón
todo el empeño el trabajo
lo importante es primero definir una
cosa es lo más importante en tu vida
y finalmente tenemos miedo al cambio
porque el cambio implica dejar de pensar
de una forma significa generar hábitos
costumbres formas diferentes de hacer
las cosas muchas veces nos conformamos
aunque ojo esto que estoy viviendo no
está tan mal no podría estar mejor pero
lo que me quedo aquí y a través de tus
pensamientos nos evitamos tener cosas
importantes para nosotros
creo que hoy es fundamental en una forma
diferente de verdasco
pero que muchas veces nos enfocamos a
ver solamente lo negativo de las fotos
lo que está mal
las limitaciones los problemas no digo
que esté mal tener un espíritu crítico
pos la crítica siempre que sea
constructiva es el primer paso para
avanzar pero qué tal
y esto lo cambiamos en lugar de mirar
estas puestas negativas tenemos el otro
extremo del espectro nos enfocamos en
los recursos en las cosas positivas
y en todos los objetivos buenos que
podemos tener es cambiar la forma en que
vemos las cosas
es tener una mirada apreciativa y cuando
hablo de tener una medidad mirad
apreciativa me refiero a valorar las
cosas
hay dos conceptos que son totalmente
antagónicos y diferentes que en función
de cuál de ellas tú decidas usar vas a
hacer una diferencia importante en tu
vida sabemos todo lo que significa
evaluar
el valor es generar una comparación la
medida que tú te comparas siempre haber
una persona que va a ser mejor a ti en
algo así en lugar de baluarte usted
valora vas encontrar a todas aquellas
cosas positivas en lugar de enfocarte y
que nos alcanzó el objetivo es que valor
es lo que tú has puesto en el camino es
simplemente cambiar los otros con
queremos una situación
el viejito de la historia nos decía que
las personas vamos a ver solamente
aquello que queremos ver que tiene razón
lastimosamente esta es la mala noticia y
en función a lo que creemos es que vamos
a ver la vida pero la buena que está en
la medida que tú tengas la capacidad de
tomar conciencia de sustentamiento si
sus creencias y cuestionar te la has
dado el primer paso para el cambio real
yo creo fervientemente en la diferencia
y el cambio real recibe el interior de
cada persona el cambio real no es algo
que está afuera
y no es esperar que cambie la situación
que cambian las circunstancias para que
ellos realmente empiece a ir y richard
para aquellos que quieran no tenemos que
esperar que las circunstancias sean
otras parís y sueños muchas veces
dejamos pasar el tiempo esperando que
algo suceda pero mientras tanto lo único
que pasa es la vida o cometemos el error
de pensar de que yo voy a hacer más
feliz en la medida que tenga más cosas
voy a ser feliz cuando tenga dinero
cuando empiece a ganar dinero cuando
tengo un auto cuando tengo una casa ya
veces cuando ya tenemos estos bienes
queremos seguir teniendo más darnos
cuenta de la felicidad verdadera no es
en las cosas buenas que te pasan no es
como tú interpretas las cosas malas
yo creo fervientemente el cambio real
comienza aquí en la mente en la medida
que tú tengas la capacidad de cuestionar
es tiempo de pensamientos que tienen
pero también comienza aquí en el corazón
en la medida que tú escuchas las voces
en ascendente
[Aplausos]
[Música]